java rashood is offer we received a
number of contributions that were
provided that are quite close to the
figure of 60,000 individuals under 20
2504 is the figure for resettlement and
30 2256 f or relocation a total of fifty
4760 let example the most important
thing today is that the work of
implementation can start as of now and
that is crucial in specific terms the
first individuals can be relocated as of
October of this year yeah I wish you
Nadia Guillermo would also point out
that another council decision taken
today was that the council adopted the
provisions are opening up a to the
Western Balkan country so which should
be seen as a safe harbors and this is
the first time in the history of the
European Union and of the European
migration policy that relocation efforts
will be undertaken we now have the hot
spots this new approach offers a
coordinated platform for European Union
agencies not only a Ozil Frontex and
Europol to intervene rapidly at Europe's
external borders in this case Italy and
Greece as the midnight today the common
European asylum system will be complete
giving the European Union the highest
asylum standards worldwide